another thing that dr bright is not
allowed to do at the foundation no
interacting with scp-5555-j
under any circumstances scp-5555-j
is capable of reducing any living
organism to a miniature or chibi if
you'd prefer version of itself dr bright
may claim he is trying to make teacup
pigs to hand out at the office as an
incentive but do not fall for it the
last time dr bright was exposed to
scp-5555-j
the miniature version it produced of him
was a miniature orangutan he was brought
into custody and proceeded to behave
quite poorly with some of his own
bathroom material and completely destroy
the attending researcher's clothing
before escaping to wreck even more havoc
dr bright knows what mini him did and he
has lost his
55-55-j privileges for good another
thing that dr bright is not allowed to
do at the foundation dr bright is not
permitted to try and solve every single
problem with chainsaws chainsaws can be
quite helpful when it comes to certain
specific tasks they're great at for
instance speedily chopping up lumber or
menacing a group of unsuspecting
teenagers on a road trip however dr
bright would like you to believe that
the application of chainsaws goes far
beyond the realm of reason or safety
chainsaws should not be used to trim
your hair to contain scp-682 to cut a
sandwich or as the ammunition in a
specialized cannon it was fine the one
time at the company christmas party we
all had a good laugh but dr james will
never get his big toe back no
more chainsaws
another series of things dr bright is
not allowed to do at the scp foundation
claim he is from an alternate timeline
issue orders to quote preserve the
timeline unquote or to quote corrupt the
timeline unquote or to quote screw those
history nerds unquote dr bright may be
cursed to live for a very long time but
he is still sadly fundamentally attached
to our timeline he may have watched loki
recently but that doesn't mean he's a
multiverse gallivanting trickster god he
only wishes he was another thing that dr
bright is not allowed to do at the scp
foundation dr bright is not allowed to
apply
scp-963 to any major political figures
again
so we've got some background here anyone
who's seen our video on
scp-4444 will know that a species of
aliens almost destroyed our planet in
the year 2000 after they possessed
presidential candidate al gore in order
to stop them dr bright needed to take
over the body of george w bush to run
against him while this was an emergency
where certain risks needed to be taken
our current geopolitical landscape is
already too wild and too fractious to
risk dr bright ever rising to any kind
of political power though if he did he'd
probably run on the major campaign
slogan ah come on guys you've had worse
another thing that dr bright is not
allowed to do dr bright cannot give
scp-082 song requests
scp-082 loves to sing if there's
anything he loves more than lying and
feasting on human flesh it's busting out
a cheerful little tune from time to time
however as dr bright has shown that he
cannot be respectful of scp-082's tastes
or the comfort of those working around
him he is not permitted to request any
songs from scp-082
ferdinand was recently reduced to tears
when his rendition of a classic italian
arya was interrupted by dr bright's
repeated cries of do free bird and he
also expressed discomfort when dr bright
told him to perform like a virgin he
should know by now that fernan only
likes to sing one madonna song and it's
vogue another thing dr bright is not
allowed to do dr bright is not allowed
to accidentally spill green gelatin on a
dead body it is well known by scp staff
particularly those in the o5 council
that allowing
scp-447's green slime to come into
contact with the dead body will result
in disaster on a catastrophic scale of
course dr bright decided that it would
be hilarious to procure some lime jell-o
from the canteen pretend to trip and
fall and spill the gelatin all over a
body being observed by the o5 admittedly
the first time it was a bit funny but it
was also extremely stressful multiple
staff fainted and 05-2 made it a point
to tell dr bright that he owed him a new
pair of khakis after the sudden terror
had made him well ruin his
another thing that dr bright is not
allowed to do at the foundation dr
bright is not allowed to speed date if
you remember an event called scp speed
dating please report to site command
immediately for your mandatory dose of
class a amnestic this event never
officially took place and there is no
public record of it dr bright certainly
did not pack the canteen with safe class
humanoid as cps and employees of the
foundation and ding a bell every five
minutes so that eligible singles could
switch tables and meet someone new there
were no public displays of affection on
foundation grounds and certainly no
ensuing disastrous dates at any local
italian restaurants dr bright is not
allowed to organize a speed dating event
ever again
um
i mean for for the first time because
there has never been one not here
no sir another thing dr bright is not
allowed to do at the foundation he is
not allowed to use
scp-705 for personal gain the plato toy
soldiers are highly entertaining to
watch and it's understandable to be
curious about their potential
applications but dr bright has taken it
too far he used the tiny soldiers to
plant hidden cameras and microphones in
his colleagues offices not only is this
a violation of their privacy but it's
also just plain creepy and it's unfair
to make scp-705 instances accomplices to
your bad behavior and if they'd known
the hidden surveillance equipment was
intended for blackmail or for stealing a
secret lasagna recipe that's been in dr
giada's family for generations they
never would have agreed another thing dr
bright is not allowed to do at the
foundation dr bright is not permitted to
assign the designation over 9 000
to any anomalies dr bright is to be
reminded that first of all the scp
foundation does not track the power
levels of any of its anomalies as that
is a completely subjective notion adding
it's over nine thousand
two official foundation documents is
distracting and confusing particularly
when applied to entities like scp-999
who have no interest in combat second of
all he should know that joke hasn't been
relevant in over a decade he's
embarrassing himself and none of the new
research assistants even know what he's
referencing finally he's not as good as
doing the vegeta voice as he thinks he
is update your references dr bright
you're better than that maybe another
thing dr bright is not allowed to do
with the foundation when writing a
report more detail is expected than
object class ketter special containment
procedures data expunged description
data expunged and inventing new security
clearances just so nobody can see what
you've written is also considered poor
form we know sometimes race can get a
little redaction happy we understand the
frustration but that's frankly no excuse
to fill your documents with nonsense and
then hide them from us if you keep doing
this we'll send technical researcher
rosen after you and we both know that
guy's a huge jerk mark our words dr
right we are not bluffing even if you do
claim to have security clearance level
420
nice
another thing dr bright is not allowed
to do with the foundation showing monty
python episodes to scp-239 was not a
wise decision please never try this with
any other reality warping scp seriously
dr bright the witch child is a reality
warper so powerful we need to keep her
in a comatose state to stop her from
permanently reformatting our universe do
you really think it's a good idea to
show her flying circus or the holy grail
if we find that by sheer coincidence we
later need to contain an anomaly that
shares a remarkable resemblance to the
black beast of
we know exactly who is responsible and
we will not take this indiscretion
lightly we might even make you sit on
the comfy chair another thing dr bride
is not allowed to do with the foundation
dr bright is not allowed to kick
scp-2558-j
scp-2558-j refers to a group of
seemingly ordinary kittens who display
friendly and affectionate behavior
towards humans and each other when
startled or made to feel afraid the
kittens inflate into a fluffy spherical
shape about the size of a soccer ball
able to move around by rolling dr bride
is not permitted to kick any of the
kittens whether they are in ball form or
not he is also strictly prohibited from
playing dodgeball volleyball or any
ball-based game with scp-2558-j
the only way anyone is permitted to play
with the kittens is using the
foundation-sanctioned cat toys provided
upon request for crying out loud man
they're kittens
another thing dr bright is not allowed
to do with the foundation dr bride is
not allowed to play hippocratic oath
chicken with the medical staff the
hippocratic oath is deeply important to
all medical professionals including
those on staff at the scp foundation dr
bride is not permitted to try and
convince the medical staff to break the
hippocratic oath in any way he is
especially not allowed to expose them to
potentially dangerous anomalies while
taunting still want to do no harm you
sure it's a waste of time resources and
it's just plain rude one of these days
they're going to snap and slap him
across the face and not one of us will
stop them another thing dr bright is not
allowed to do at the foundation dr
bright the foundation motto is not let's
use it on 682. dr bright is to be
reminded that the foundation's only
official motto is secure contain protect
it is not in fact any of the
alternatives he has suggested this
includes but is not limited to and we
put it in 914 blood makes the grass grow
kill kill kill throw t-class at it until
it stops when in doubt feed it to 682
slapstick clowns and puns or snap
crackle and pop the last one got us
served a cease and desist from kellogg's
and we can not afford another lawsuit
right now cut it out
a note to all scp foundation staff if dr
bright has to ask it's above his
clearance level if it's above bright's
security clearance run dr bright is one
of the scp foundation's most illustrious
researchers and as site director of site
19 there's very little under the
foundation's purview that he can't do so
if you find dr bright is poking his
stolen nose where it shouldn't be then
believe me you definitely shouldn't be
there think of all the terrifying
entities you know about from the scp
foundation files now imagine all the
horrifying things you don't know about
another thing dr bright is not allowed
to do at the foundation dr bright is not
allowed to send emails with memetic
hazards attached no not even when
replying to spam dr brightweed don't
care how annoying it is when your inbox
fills up with suspicious links linda's
annoying quote of the day and chain
letters telling you that you have to
forward the email to 10 people or have
bad luck for a year that doesn't make it
okay to reply with scp-2774
attached that goes for any other memetic
hazard the last thing we need is more
instances of these hazards floating
around in cyberspace take a breath stand
up from the keyboard and let the spam
filter do its job
another thing dr bright is not allowed
to do at the scp foundation dr bride
cannot use my evil twin did it as a
viable excuse the same goes for my good
twin did it considering the implication
weirder things have happened at the scp
foundation than having an evil twin so
maybe someone could make the excuse that
their evil twin committed some crimes on
their behalf but the bride family is one
of the most well-known dynasties in
foundation history so nobody's going to
believe that there's a hidden member of
the family still out there maybe if
scp-963 had a perfect copy you might
have an excuse here but to the best of
our knowledge that is not the case take
your lumps jack another thing dr bryant
is not allowed to do at the scp
foundation dr bright is not allowed to
use for the emperor as justification for
any decision for starters the scp
foundation is independent from the
commands of any single nation it is an
autonomous non-profit organization and
you know that secondly the only country
in the world that still has an active
emperor is japan and his role is purely
ceremonial because japan is a
constitutional monarchy and just for the
record for the o5 council and for the
administrator are also unacceptable
unless the order you're acting on
actually comes from them
another thing dr bright is not allowed
to do at the foundation dr bright is no
longer allowed to offer the solution of
use more guns to any problem dr bright
look at me we went over this before with
the chainsaws do you remember
we really need to do this again i guess
so we face a wide variety of problems
here at the foundation of varying
degrees of severity there's no
one-size-fits-all solution for these
problems and even if there was it would
not be use more guns or get bigger guns
this includes but is not limited to
old-fashioned dueling pistols machine
guns or something called the octogun
which my notes say were just eight guns
taped together how does that even work
never mind don't answer that the point
is it's not helpful and dr bright is not
allowed in the armory not even on his
birthday
another thing dr bright is not allowed
to do at the foundation the ultimate
showdown of ultimate destiny is not
grounds to pit more than 15 combinative
scps against each other okay who let dr
bride onto youtube unsupervised whoever
it is you're in big trouble because dr
wright watched the ultimate showdown of
ultimate destiny and it gave him some
pretty destructive ideas watching batman
fight godzilla made him think about
throwing another giant lizard into
combat and he attempted to organize in
his words a grand tournament where 15 of
the most powerful and violent scps would
battle each other in a makeshift
coliseum this is not permitted under any
circumstances yes even if you film it
and post it on youtube
another thing dr bright is not allowed
to do with the scp foundation yes forum
trolls are annoying no they don't
automatically become d-class personnel
dr bright personally we think that
someone who's lived as long as you and
died multiple times would have thicker
skin but your repeated insistence to
turn formites like booty hunter 69 and
danky danky literature club 420 nice
into d-class personnel is as bizarre and
sad as they are nonsensical people need
to be truly despicable to warrant having
a place among the ranks of d-class
personnel they need to be truly
monstrous evil underhanded unethical
bottom of the barrel individuals and
frankly forum trolls do not fit the bill
youtube commenters on the other hand
another thing dr bright is not allowed
to do with the foundation no placing
pranks in new staff's desks and
liquefying them in record time starting
a new job can be a stressful experience
figuring out the office culture choosing
a coffee cup in the break room and
deciding which funko pops look best on
your desk it's a lot to think about the
last thing a new employee needs is to
sit down at their brand new desk open a
drawer to grab a pen and have their
flesh melted from their skull by a
bright blast of mysterious green light
it's not funny we're not impressed
anymore and staff turnover at the
foundation is already high enough as it
is
no more pranks it's not a rite of
passage if they don't survive at dr
bright
another thing dr bright is not allowed
to do at the foundation no unsupervised
access to scp-387
scp-387 or the living lego is a
miraculous find it is a tub of seemingly
ordinary lego bricks that when built
into a shape by human hands comes to
life and even develops sentience of
course dr bright can never let a cool
thing just exist without wrecking some
havoc with it and decided to build a
tiny lifelike model of
scp-682 we have no idea how he built it
so fast or why it took military-grade
explosives to blow apart the creature
made from plastic blocks but it was a
mess to clean up and agent johnson will
never get his big toe back if dr bright
is so desperate to play with legos he'll
just have to stick to the non-magic kind
another thing dr bright is not allowed
to do no bets concerning xk class end of
the world scenarios it's the one thing
we hope to avoid an xk-class scenario an
event that results in the complete and
utter destruction of the world most of
us prefer not to think about it at all
unless we're actively trying to prevent
it not dr bright though he sees the
apocalypse as a chance to make a quick
buck dr bright is officially prohibited
from making accepting or taking any rake
off bets related to xk class scenarios
these include but are not limited to
i'll bet you a thousand bucks the robots
get us first it'll all start with ducks
and not with a bang but with a whimper
another thing dr bite is not allowed to
do
no showing bad movies to scp-682
hey that rhymed
scp-682 is famous for a lot of things
its indestructible nature its insatiable
appetite for violence and the
overflowing well of hate in its heart
unsatisfied with scp-682's ordinary
level of rage dr bright decided to take
it upon himself to give the lizard even
more things to be angry about an
organized and informal so bad it's good
film festival for the anomaly and
himself the resulting damage and loss of
life cost the foundation thousands of
dollars movies on the do not show to 682
list include the works of ua bowl the
work of neil breen the room troll 2
manos the hands of fate and let's face
it any other movie dr bright can think
of no
more
movies
another thing dr bright is not allowed
to do with the foundation dr bryant is
not allowed to classify any researcher
including himself as a memetic hazard
memetic hazards are not to be taken
lightly many of the scp foundation's
best and brightest have been cut down in
their prime by memetic hazards that ate
away at their sanity and destroyed their
minds just because dr bright likes
singing the song that never ends and
annoying everyone that does not make him
a memetic hazard by foundation standards
other behaviors that do not qualify a
researcher as a memetic hazard include
but are not limited to whistling all the
time clipping their nails at their desk
or microwaving fish in the break room
another thing dr bright is not allowed
to do at the foundation no claiming to
be or to have ever been steve irwin how
dare you steve irwin was an
international treasure and you will
never ever
fill his sensible shoes dr bright no
matter how much you say crikey when
looking at scp-682
no matter how many times you call it a
mighty big croc no matter how much you
photoshop yourself into photos of
scp-682
or how many australians you possess you
will never be the crocodile hunter stop
trying to make it happen no one is going
to call you that and stop tricking
interns into buying autographed
memorabilia from you we all know it's a
forgery another thing dr bright is not
allowed to do at the foundation no
changing the standard issue d-class
uniform dr bright is always proposing
changes at the scp foundation and nearly
all of them should be disregarded
immediately the d-class uniform is
perfect the way it is and does not need
to be changed it especially does not
need to be changed to black pants with a
red polo shirt we get what you're going
for dr bright it's very clever we also
enjoy star trek but in addition to it
being a waste of resources to produce
all these new uniforms we just don't
want a lawsuit from paramount global on
our hands
another thing dr bright is not allowed
to do with the foundation no playing hot
potato with scp-963
scp-963 is the ornate anomalous amulet
that contains dr jack bright's
consciousness any living subject that
comes into contact with this amulet
ceases brain function and their
consciousness is replaced with dr
brights if they remain in contact with
the amulet for longer than 30 days they
will retain this consciousness even
after the amulet has been removed
otherwise they will experience brain
death
essentially it should be taken
incredibly seriously and handled with
great care it should not be tossed at a
random d-class research assistant or any
other foundation staff member with
shouts of catch or use to play any other
high-stakes contact-based game it is not
in fact a fun team-building exercise
that should be played on company
retreats